Before Will Smith headed to the Wild Wild
West, he breezed right by The Matrix.
In a new video posted to his personal YouTube
channel, Smith dropped a bombshell: he turned
down the opportunity to star as Neo in The
Matrix.
"I did turn down Neo in The Matrix."
Smith had previously admitted in a 2004 Wired
interview that he did turn down the role,
but in his new video, he finally gives the
full story and explains the circumstances
that pushed him to reject the offer.
The actor rewound the clock to 1996 to tell
the tale from the very beginning.
That year, Smith was wrapping up the final
season of The Fresh Prince of Bel-Air, the
sitcom series that put him on the map and
made him a household name, and was basking
in the sweet waters of success following the
release of Independence Day, which remains
one of the highest-grossing films in all of
cinema history.
"Who's the man?
Who's the man?"
It's little wonder why Lana and Lilly Wachowski,
the writers and directors of The Matrix, wanted
Smith to lead the film: he was gaining star
power by the second and seemed virtually untouchable.
But Smith had clear-cut intentions for his
career moving forward, not wanting to isolate
himself to a certain kind of genre in apparent
fear of being type-cast.
This led him to initially turn down Men in
Black two years prior to saying no to The
Matrix.
"I had done Independence Day the year before,
so I was like, eh, I'm not doing another alien
movie.
I don't want to be the alien movie guy.
So I turned down Men in Black, and Steven
Spielberg called me.
He was producing.
He was like, 'Why are you turning down the
movie?'
I was like, 'You know, I just don't want to
be the alien guy.'"
He went on to say that he took Spielberg's
advice and eventually joined Men in Black
and felt on top of the world for a short while
after the film's debut in July of 1997.
You just get in that universal energy, and
nothing can go wrong.
But then the other side comes, and you can't
do nothing right."
Smith then brought us up to 1998, post-Men
in Black and pre-The Matrix, when he had some
big decisions to make.
"So after we did Men in Black, the Wachowskis
came in, and it was like they had only done
one movie.
[...] They came in and they made a pitch for
The Matrix, and it turns out, they're geniuses."
Still, Smith shared that the Wachowskis' idea
for The Matrix didn't strike his fancy.
In fact, the Wachowskis' apparent laid back
behavior and strange pitch completely confused
Smith.
Putting on a California surfer-type accent
to impersonate the Wachowskis, Smith described
the pitch:
"Imagine if you could stop jumping in the
middle of the jump … But then people could
see around you 360 [degrees] while you're
jumping,
"Nice to see an invention that actually works."
The Wachowskis' pitch for The Matrix ultimately
put Smith off the project.
Instead, he made the steampunk Western action
comedy Wild Wild West — a low point in Smith's
professional life.
Still, Smith has no regrets about turning
down The Matrix.
The actor feels he actually did movie-lovers
a great justice in rejecting the offer to
play Neo, admitting that he likely would have
screwed up The Matrix if he led the film and
not Keanu Reeves.
"I probably would have messed The Matrix up.
I would have ruined it.
So I did y'all a favor."
Considering Smith already experienced wariness
at the thought of doing too many sci-fi action
movies back-to-back, he may not have given
the role of Neo the attention that it required.
The actor was essentially prioritizing goofiness
over anything else back in the late 1990s.
"And that would be my belt buckle.
Gordon, when you're telling this story to
your grandkids, you make sure that you leave
this part out."
He very well could have taken a wildly different
approach to Neo than did Reeves, resulting
in a version of the character that was unable
to hit all the right emotional beats.
As many Matrix fans will agree, no one but
the reserved, somewhat steely Reeves could
play Neo perfectly.
"I know kung fu."
At the end of it all, as much as everyone,
Smith included, despised Wild Wild West, we're
glad Smith chose to make it over taking the
lead role in The Matrix.
In a way, Smith stumbled in Wild Wild West
so Reeves could soar in The Matrix - and that
decision genuinely may have saved not just
the first film but also the entire franchise.
"Now that's what I call a close encounter."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.